je chemine solitaire sur cette terre
depuis longtemps des tâches et du
plaisir de la vie nul compagnon de
partage le secret de mon coeur jamais
aucune arme n'a su comprendre je fuis le
monde et toutes ces joies je suis bien
loin aujourd'hui des humains leur
bonheur et leur peine me reste étranger
je chemine solitaire comme sur une autre
planète
oh vous cher à mme de ces temps
lointains auquel s'adresse aujourd'hui
mon âme bien souvent elle vous
accompagnera et vous la ferez vivre
grâce à mes poèmes
chaque année à l'approché du printemps
leduc max en bavière et son épouse la
duchesse ludovic a quitt munich pour
poser nos fans et sur les rives du lac
de m
depuis son mariage en 1828
le couple a donné naissance à huit
enfants sissi est le troisième de cette
union heureuse elle est née la veille du
jour de noël 1837 et on la bâtisse
elizabeth en l'honneur de sa tante la
reine de prusse
le
mais elle sera cependant toute sa vie
surnommé affectueusement 6,6 de tous ses
frères et soeur elisabeth est la plus
turbulente
il y avait des moments écrit la baronne
val fun où il eût fallu littéralement la
fille sol et sur une chaise dans cette
famille un peu bohème elisabeth grandi
entouré d'affection insouciante et libre
son père le duc maximilien est un prince
excentrique aimant par dessus tout la
nature poète à ses heures il est en
outre un excellent joueur de sitar
cavaliers hors pair il a fait construire
dans sa résidence de munich un manège où
il dresse lui même ses chevaux son
épouse quant à elle est une femme
modeste et pieuse elisabeth est sensible
aux paysages romantiques de sa bavière
natale et confient déjà c'est secret à
son journal intime très proche de son
père elle accompagne dans ses promenades
à cheval
leduc maximilien confiera un jour à sa
fille si toi et moi nous n'étions pas né
prince
nous aurions été écuyer dans un cirque
pendant l'été 1853 la duchesse ludovic a
accompagné de ses filles hélène et
elisabeth rendre visite à
l'archiduchesse sophie qui est en
villégiature à bakchich ce petit village
perché dans les montagnes et la
résidence d'été de la famille impériale
d'autriche
fille
cette rencontre est l'occasion pour
l'empereur françois-joseph d'annoncer
ses fiançailles officielles avec sa
cousine hélène ce sérieux jeune homme de
23 ans est devenu depuis le 2 décembre
1848 le nouvel empereur d'autriche
mais à la surprise générale la charmante
6,6 éclipse hélène aux yeux du jeune
empereur ce sera elizabeth où aucune
autre femme annonce françois joseph à sa
mère c'est ici si charmante avec cette
magnifique couronne de cheveux autour de
son visage
cette exubérance deux petites filles
encore et pourtant cette douceur
le jour de leurs fiançailles
françois-joseph offre à elizabeth une
couronne de roses et lui dit c'est le
plus beau jour de ma vie je te dois mon
bonheur et je te remercie d'avoir
éclairé mon existence
les neufs sont fixées au mois d'avril
1854 un avenir exceptionnelle s'ouvre
alors devant elisabeth longtemps la
veille de son départ pour vienne
si c'est écrit dans son journal à dieu
demeure silencieuse adieu vieux château
et mes premiers rêves d'amour vous
saluerait encore le mois de mai mais
aujourd'hui je vous dis adieu mais
enchérit je fais être si loin de vous
vienne est en fête pour saluer l'arrivée
de la future impératrice des drapeaux
aux couleurs de la bavière flottent au
vent et un nouveau pont sur le danube a
été spécialement construit en son
honneur
alors qu'elle traverse la ville dans un
carrosse vitré aux panneaux peints par
rubens et or ou incrusté d'or chacun
essaye de la voir de plus près de lui
voler les sourires
le mariage a lieu le lendemain le 24
avril 1854 coiffé d'une couronne d'opale
et de diamants elisabeth porte une robe
de dentelle blanche tissé de fils
d'argent
pas les angoisses et la jeune mariée de
17 ans arrive au seuil de l'église les
augustins où l'attendent
tous les membres du clergé et les
représentants de la famille impériale
lorsque les futurs époux échangent leurs
alliances et leur consentement
le cardinal prononçant serment éloquente
aux côtés de françois joseph héros et
sauveur de l'autriche son impérial
compagne resplendira comme la première
entre toutes les femmes par les vertus
qui du haut de son trône répandront sur
le peuple leur douce et attirante année
on
très vite elisabeth est confrontée à la
rigidité de l'étiquette espagnol qui
règne à l'accord des habsbourgs et qui
règle en détail ses moindres faits et
gestes
en effet la jeune impératrice est trop
spontanée pour se plier sans réticence
aux exigences du cérémonial de charles
quint à la table impérial tout le monde
est muet personne n'a le droit
d'interroger l'empereur si sa majesté
pose une question on doit y répondre en
quelques mots toute conversation général
est proscrite
ces plaisirs d'autrefois comme boire de
la bière à table ils sont désormais
interdits
dans les grands salons un personnel du
palais de schönbrunn
elisabeth a du mal à trouver sa place
quelle angoisse y ressenti dans ce monde
étrange et de grandes personnes
comme tout me paraissait différents
cependant elle trouve la force de jouer
son rôle d'impératrice dans l'amour que
lui porte françois joseph l'empereur
manifeste à chaque instant une grande
tendresse à celle qu'il appelle mon ange
adoré
de temps à autre elisabeth réussi à se
soustraire à ses obligations et
s'échappe pour de longues promenades
elle écrit alors un poème dont le titre
est un aveu nostalgie que m'importe à
moi le charme du printemps dans ce pays
d'exil je me languis de toi soleil de
monter de vous rives de l'isard de vous
arbres sombres et de toi fleuve vers qui
doucement la nuit dans mes rêves m'a
chuchoté un au revoir
sous le ciel bleu je languis dans ma
prison l'effroi barreau de mes fenêtres
1 suite à ma nostalgie
dès l'arrivée des beaux jours elizabeth
découvre une château de laxenburg à 15
km de vienne
nous
enfin seuls loin des obligations
officielles
l'empereur et l'impératrice parts à
cheval sans escorte dans l'immense parc
de 250 hectares qui entoure le château
mais elizabeth va devoir renoncer aux
promenades à cheval car elle attend un
enfant
en effet le 5 mars
1855 l'impératrice donne naissance à une
fille prénommée sophie l'année suivante
nouvelle déception elle donne le jour à
une seconde fille gisèle après
naissances avec autorité sa belle-mère
l'archiduchesse sophie fait installer
l'enfant dans ses propres appartements
trop accaparés par les obligations de sa
charge
françois joseph n'a pas conscience du
déchirement et de la frustration que
cela provoque chez son épouse 1856 le
couple impérial se rend en italie
françois-joseph espère que la présence
d'elisabeth saura apaiser leur sentiment
qui règne contre l'autriche
l'accueil à venise et glacial la jeune
impératrice prend conscience des
brutalités commises par le gouvernement
autrichien et un site françois joseph à
la clémence un revirement se produit
dans l'opinion et les vénitiens distel
elle à la figure d'une madone et le
coeur d'un ange
mai 1857 le voyage se poursuit en
hongrie elisabeth est sensible aux
charmes de budapest à ses lumières qui
se reflète dans le d'années elle a
immédiatement le sentiment d'avoir un
rôle de protectrice à tenir dans ce pays
elle apprécie la culture hongroise et
très vite les hongrois comprenne qu'elle
va défendre la cause de leur patrie
dès qu'elle dispose d'un peu de temps
libre l'impératrice galope dans la
campagne et se délecte de la beauté des
paysages
un drame survient alors la petite sophie
décède des suites d'une dysenterie les
106 si désespérée sa terrible belle-mère
l'accablent de reproches
heureusement la paire actrice va mettre
au monde un nouvel enfant un petit
garçon
rodolphe donnant ainsi à la couronne
l'héritier si par damman attendu nous
avons un garçon superbe je suis
extrêmement heureux dit alors l'empereur
à sa femme quel homme ce sera notre
petit prince de la couronne au début de
l'année 1859 la situation l'italie se
dégrade et françois joseph part sur le
front plus seul que jamais il n'avait
pas séjourné a visité des hôpitaux et
réconforter les blessés
à chaque instant elle songe à l'empereur
qui pourrait être allongée parmi les
victimes de la guerre elle songe à la
mort est folle d'inquiétude pour celui à
qui le destin l'allier elle se sent
impuissante dans son grand palais
tellement seule et abandonnée
un jour enfin elle reçoit une lettre
tant attendu françois joseph lui annonce
son retour j'ai appris à connaître les
sentiments d'un général battu ma seule
consolation me se jouer maintenant dalet
rejoindre un ange lui imagine combien je
me réjouis tant dévoué françois fuir
fuir la co telle est la nouvelle
obsession d'elisabeth nerveuse est
malade elle rêve d'une île au milieu de
l'océan où le printemps serait éternelle
ce sera ma mère dans sa villa qui
surplombe la mer les yeux fermés elle
écoute levon qui froisse les feuilles
des oliviers et vagues déferlantes
enfin seule elle se nourrit de beauté et
d'exotisme
lentement elle se sent revivre mais
cette jeune femme de 25 ans sensible et
fragile et déjà d'une étrange et
profonde invités l'opératrice lis
souvent mais surtout elle écrit parfois
des textes d'une surprenante beauté
nous devons tous nous pencher sur le
coeur de la terre est en écoute et les
battements la conf lui comme une conque
mystique les grande harmonie tous les
rayons du soleil qui jamais ne
s'éteignent et les raves qui ne sont pas
encore nés
après madère la grèce sur les traces
d'ulysse voyageur passionné
elisabeth gagne corfou sur cette île
couverte d'orange et aux fleurs qui
émergent des flots elle est apaisée
avant de partir elle écrit un dernier
regard sur toi mère bien aimée quand
demain les rayons du soleil caresseront
d'un coup d'aile rapide
j'aurais volé au loin venise elisabeth
avant de rentrer à vienne s'accorde
encore un peu de répit elle redécouvre
avec plaisir l'élégance de cette ville
bâtie sur les où elle retrouve ce
qu'elle a laissé derrière elle ses
chiens chats d'eau et plateaux que
françois joseph lui a fait envoyer pour
qu'elle ne soit pas seule
et bientôt c'est avec un immense bonheur
qu'elle retrouve l'empereur surtout ses
enfants gisèle et rodolphe âgé à présent
de cinq et trois ans durant ses voyages
elle n'a cessé de leur écrire et
sellette s'est terminé toujours par
semaine n'oubliez pas votre maman pense
et quelquefois à votre maman
plus mûr peut-être elizabeth a décidé de
vivre en paix avec sa belle-mère sur le
bateau du retour elle songe déjà au
fardeau des obligations qui l'attend à
vienne deux ans déjà deux ans que
lisabeth n'est parvenue à vienne elle
retrouve ses lieux avec une assurance
nouvelle elle va montrer à tous qu'elle
et l'impératrice
dans les bals de la cour elisabeth et
plus superbe que jamais on se bouscule
pour la voir danser ou admirer son
élégance
derrière cette fine silhouette et ce
gracieux visage se cache une âme
généreuse elizabeth se sent proche de
son peuple et se penche sur le malheur
de chacun lorsqu elles rendent visite
aux pauvres inlassablement elle visite
les institutions charitables et apporte
à tous réconfort et chaleur ainsi est
faite la vie d'elizabeth partagé entre
les fêtes somptueuses et les obligations
entraîné par la vie comme par une valse
on y vante elle sait qu'elle ne peut pas
échapper à cette destinée qui fit d'elle
la femme de l'empereur d'autriche
les 866 la guerre éclate à nouveau et
très vite l'armée autrichienne subi
l'écrasante défaite de shadow va il
avait écrit l'empereur est admirable
toujours calme et résolue malgré son
désir de rester près de françois-joseph
à l'heure du péril elizabeth doit partir
avec ses enfants chercher un refuge en
engrais car l'armée ennemie et aux
portes de vienne à budapest
l'impératrice est reçu avec enthousiasme
elle habite le palais royal et les
hongrois la considère très vite comme
leur reine à tel point que les
parlementaires la prit officiellement de
se laisser couronné en même temps que
l'empereur leur déclare alors c'est avec
joie que j'accède au désir de la nation
et je bénis la providence de me faire
vivre ce moment grandiose la veille du
couronnement
comme le veut le cérémonial la future
reine de hongrie raccommode de ses
propres mains le manteau du sacre et le
8 juin 1867 sous les cris de joie de la
foule
le couple royal traverse la ville puis
françois joseph accompli les rites
traditionnels et promet de défendre la
hongrie contre ses ennemis le souhait
d'elisabeth et réaliser n'at-elle pas
déclarés si les affaires de l'empereur
vont mal en italie cela me peine si
elles vont mal en hongrie cela me tue
rayonnante dans la robe que le couturier
parisien worf à créer sur le modèle du
costume traditionnel hongrois elisabeth
suscite l'admiration de tous un témoin
du couronnement le compositeur liste
dira je ne l'avais jamais vu si belle
elle apparaissait comme une vision
céleste dans le déroulement d'un fast
barbe à l'empereur en uniforme maillard
est fier d'être couronné aux côtés de
seth rennes laquelle un poète hongrois
déclare la plus grande politique est de
gagner le coeur d'une nation ainsi que
votre majesté l'a fait de la hongrie
grâce à l' influence d'elisabeth le
compte du l'andra ci est nommé ministre
des affaires étrangères
elisabeth se crée un nouveau cercle
intime ses 14 dan d'honneur sont toutes
hongroise ida ferenczi est la préférée
d'elisabeth qui ne l'appelle que ma
douce ida et la comtesse festetics
acquis elizabeth a dit simplement soyez
franche et loyale est pour elle une
confidente et une amie d'une fidélité à
toute épreuve
en 1867 le couple impérial reçoit en
présent de la nation hongroise le
château de but de le situer à 28 km de
budapest dans la campagne hongroise
l'espère enfin avoir trouvé un havre de
paix un lieu dans lequel elles puissent
vivre parmi ceux qu'elle aime et oublier
cette tristesse qui jamais ne la
quittent tout à fait
dans ce très beau palais elle a fait
aménager à sa convenance nombre de
petites pièces intimes aux murs
recouverts de tissu couleur lilas sa
teinte favorite
assise à son secrétaire élisabeth écrit
de longues lettres aux aides qui lui
sont le plus chers
madou sida ce matin j'ai reçu la lettre
et je suis très heureuse que tu te
portent bien
quand tu reviendras je serai encore à
godollo il fait si beau que je me
réjouis de monter à cheval en toute
liberté
surtout maintenant car j'ai reçu la
permission d'aller seul voir les écuries
à dieu maintenant et je te prie d'écrire
de nouveaux attaché à me isabelle et
lieu de le est entouré de forêt et au
delà des epesses futé une immense plaine
entraîne le regard à perte de vue du
jeune aristocrate sportif et fortunés
comme le prince n'est qu' esterhazy le
prince rodolphe de liechtenstein ou le
compte du l'andra s'ils forment la
société habituel de lieu de le où l'on
chasse trois fois par semaine elisabeth
participe à toutes les chasses
n'hésitant pas à prendre des risques
mais suscitant l'admiration des nobles
maillard prêt à se rompre le cou pour
escorter leur belle reine
lorsqu'elle ne chasse pas elizabeth
bryant le cavaliere se perfectionne en
équitation comme son père autrefois elle
a fait installer un manège dans lequel
elle s'entraîne durant de longues heures
à exécuter des figures de haute école
moulée dans sa robe noire d'amazon un
chapeau de soi perché sur sa chevelure
avec ses hautes bottines lacées
elisabeth ressens une joie incomparable
à monter ses plus beaux chevaux pour
avoir une silhouette irréprochable
la coquette impératrice fait coudre ses
robes d'équitation sur elle à même le
corps
on veut tout
dans le cadre enchanteur de godollo les
obligations qui pèsent moins elle prend
plaisir à organiser des bals
le 22 avril 1868 la petite marie valérie
voit le jour l'enfant ne tarde pas à
devenir la préférée d'elisabeth qu'il
élève avec un soin jaloux
elle expliquera un jour à sa fille pour
mes autres enfants ma belle mère avait
pris ma place mais je me disais qu'avec
toi cela devait changer dès le premier
instant tu devais m'appartenir en toute
propriété être le bijou sur lequel nul
ne devait avoir de droit or moi seul
j'ai ensuite déversée sur toi toute la
capacité de mon coeur jusque là fermé
à vienne elisabeth lutte pour préserver
son intimité narcissique
elle a le souci extrême de son corps
dans ses appartements de la hofburg elle
s'est fait installer un véritable temple
de la beauté au grand scandale des
archiduchesse l'impératrice rendait pas
entièrement dévêtu elle fait
quotidiennement le longues séances de
gymnastique dans une salle équipée de
barzeh d'âne ou son professeur de grec
la surprend un jour je la trouvais en
train de faire les anneaux elle portait
une robe de soie noire à longue traîne
bordé de superbes plumes d'autruche
noires suspendues aux cordes
elle faisait un effet fantastiques tels
à naître entre le serpent et l'oiseau
dans le parc de chambry elisabeth fait
de longues marches à pied et seront tous
les matins à la ferme là elle boit
lentement un verre de lait frais c'est
parfois le seul aliment que s'autorisent
l'opératrice qui sastre à hauts régimes
les plus extravagants dans ce cadre
champêtre
elle goûte en secret un peu de quiétude
loin des contraintes de son quotidien
la beauté d'elisabeth fait alors
l'unanimité le jeune guillaume ii est
fasciné je regardais ce beau visage
encadré de cheveux noirs j'étais médusés
par cette apparition
l'impératrice ne s'asseyait pas mais se
pose est majestueusement elle ne se
levait pas mais s'est levé le shah de
perse et enthousiasmé c'est la femme la
plus adorable que j'ai jamais vu quelle
dignité qu'elles rires quelle bonté
si je revenais ce ne serait que pour la
voir elle
en septembre 1875 l'impératrice à qui
son médecin recommande l'air de la mer
loue un petit château à ça saute haut le
mauconduit près de fécamp
elisabeth est enchanté à l'idée de
séjourner quelques semaines dans la
campagne normande ses appartements
privés et ceux de sa fille marie valérie
sont installés au premier étage
dans le vaste parc de sassetot
l'impératrice ça donne une joyeuse mans
à l'équitation sous la direction d'anne
écuyer nous mais allen téméraire elle me
se laisse impressionner par aucune
difficulté un jour elle ne peut résister
à la tentation d'essayer un cheval
qu'elle lance sur une et le cheval se
cabre tombe sur les genoux et dans le
choc brise la sangle de la selle après
une chute extrêmement violente elisabeth
récents connaissances sur le sol
lorsqu'elle reprend ses esprits elle n'a
aucun souvenir de sa chute
le médecin craint alors une commotion
cérébrale mais quelques jours plus tard
elisabeth retrouve heureusement la
mémoire en mars 1876 l'impératrice part
pour l'angleterre
la patrie des sports équestres
elle s'installe dans les mines landes où
elle se procure les meilleurs chevaux
avec françois joseph qui est venus la
retrouver il galope dans la forêt
anglaise dans le compagnie du capitaine
baby dalton qui ne tarde pas à devenir
l'un de ses meilleurs amis
l'impératrice m organiser des parties de
chasse
non loin de vienne existe un lieu
enchanteur dans lequel elisabeth peut
s'adonner à ses rêveries tels le palais
de la belle au bois dormant
la villa hermès se trouve au coeur d'un
immense parc 6,6 aime passionnément
cette majestueuse ville a offert par
l'empereur est construite spécialement à
son intention accompagné dans ses
promenades par le dieu messager hermès
l'impératrice compose des verts je me
hâte vers le royaume des songes hautmont
m c'est là que tu es mon âme
enthousiasme et déjà vols vers toi
le monogramme d'elisabeth ornent chaque
point pour nous rappeler à quel point ce
lieu est imprégnée de l'âme de sa
propriétaire sa chambre à coucher est
dédié à l'oeuvre de shakespeare
les fresques peintes par le jeune gustav
klimt alors inconnu illustrent des
scènes du songe d'une nuit d'été
la pièce préférée de l'impératrice on y
voit titania caresser la tête d'âne de
ses illusions dans le nombreux poèmes
elisabeth s'identifiait titania chez
rame du futur
c'est à toi que je lègue mais écrit le m
me les addicts et ils devront être
publiés 60 ans après cette année il n'y
aura pas dans soixante ans plus de
bonheur et plus de paix c'est à dire de
liberté sur notre petite planète
peut-être sur une autre quand tu liras
ses lignes avec mon cordial salut car je
sens que tu me veut du bien dit amiens
c'est une impératrice l'ass qui promène
sa mélancolie dans les jardins de la
villa hermès en 1881 elisabeth donne
l'ordre de vente ses chevaux et de
fermer ces écuries à 43 ans elle renonce
à l'une de ses plus grandes passions et
s'enferme plus que jamais dans sa
solitude mais seul compagnon qu'elle
accepte sont ses chiens chats d'eau et
plateaux les aime tant qu il pose avec
elle sur toutes les photos
après leur mort lé fera enterrer tous
les deux dans le parc de goede le
un fait dafing elisabeth rencontre
régulièrement son cousin le roi louis ii
de bavière avec qui elle entretient une
correspondance exalté au toit l'aigle
qui plane sur les montagnes reçoit de la
mouette des mères le salut des vagues
écumante ou hot neiges éternelles
les deux personnages se ressemblent
fortement oui devait monter sur le trône
à la mort de son père le roi maximilien
ii à l'âge de 19 ans
délicat et sensible jeune roi vous à sa
cousine véritable passion
il ne manque jamais de lui rendre visite
lorsqu'il séjourne en matière
louis ii et excentrique et dépensier à
outrance sa passion pour wagner et les
châteaux extravagantes qu'il fait
construire le mène à sardines considéré
comme fou il est forcé d'abdiquer et
internés dans le château de berg atterré
par cette nouvelle elisabeth déclare s
donc être fou que de fuir la société des
hommes et d'aimer vivre dans la solitude
le 4 juin 1886 le voit sort du château
en compagnie de son médecin pour une
promenade vers le lac de starnberg
l'impératrice a mis au point avec l'ue
un plan d'évasion
louis 2 doit traverser le lac à la nage
et retrouver la liberté de l'autre côté
elisabeth attend longtemps sur l'autre
rive et la nuit est tombée lorsqu on
ramène sur les rivages les deux corps
sans vie du roi et du docteur gulden
louis ii disparaît ainsi la scène de ce
monde
ensevelie dans les flots comme le prince
de ces légendes qu'il est en fait
revivre dans un décret
pendant de longues semaines enfermé dans
une solitude complète l'impératrice
pleure cette affection fraternelle et si
tragiquement prisés
elle écrit en mémoire de son cousin doré
oui j'étais à roye de légende trônant
sur 1 euro chez alice grâce il était mon
sceptre de scintillantes et toiletter ma
couronne des profondes et douce vallée
des vastes et riches quand on le peuple
respectueusement se tourner vers son roi
mais là lâche racaille de cours et la
famille elle-même en secret 10 et
perfidement leurs filets ne souhaitant
que ma chute
ils envoyèrent ce billet est médecin
s'emparait de l'insensé comme traitement
le braconnier prend dans ses rets le
noble sert cette liberté qu'il voulait
me ravir cette liberté je les trouvais
dans les flots mieux valait qui si mon
coeur s'arrête que de dépérir dans un
cachot l'elizabeth l'âme en peine
queuille sur les lieux où vécut 8,2 des
roses et les gardera précieusement dans
des enveloppes se souvenant des verts
que lui écrivait son cousin il y a des
années que je n'ai pu moi même me rendre
à l'île aux roses dès que j'ai appris
qu'elle joua m'attendais là bas j'ai
volé à tire d'aile vernet idyllique et
j'ai trouvé le précieux salut de la
mouette mari
rodolphe le fils unique du couple
impérial a été élevé par sa grand mère
il possède la personnalité tourmentée si
caractéristique des membres de la maison
royale de bavière en 1880 sur l'ordre de
françois joseph et malgré la
désapprobation d'elisabeth rodolphe
épouse la princesse stéphanie de
belgique
le couple ne s'entend pas et rodolphe ne
tarde pas fuir son angoisse
existentielle en menant une vie d'excès
en tout genre
le 30 janvier 1889 rodolphe très
déprimée s'enferme dans son pavillon de
chasse a meilleure mine
il vient d'apprendre qu'une oie qu'il a
activement soutenu rejeté ses ambitions
politiques sont anéantis felipe héritier
de la couronne va prendre alors une
décision irait médias un homme naissante
des coups de feu retentissent dans le
pavillon où le silence retombe
terrifiant avant de mourir il a laissé
cette lettre à sa femme
cher stéphane et tué des livrets de maaf
une est à présent ce soir reste dans ta
destinée soit bonne pour la pauvre
petite qui la seule chose qui subsiste
de moi j'entre avait le calme dans la
mort qui seul peut sauver ma bonne
réputation tombera sans de tout coeur
produits
selon un version officielle rodolphe
s'est bien suicidé
cependant il est possible qu'il était
victime d'un assassinat politique
il sera d'ailleurs enterré
religieusement alors qu'à l'époque
l'église refuse d'accorder sa
bénédiction au suicide et près du corps
de rodolphe visait à notre corps celui
de la parole mary vetsera éperdument
amoureuse du prince sa jeune maîtresse
l'a suivi dans la mort elle a écrit une
dernière lettre à sa mère
nous sommes à présent très curieux de
savoir comment effet notre monde
pardonnez moi ce que j'ai fait je ne
pouvais résister à meaux
marie élisabeth ne sera plus jamais la
même
comme l'a décrit l'un de ses proches
elle ne rit presque jamais à mu et
sourire qui souvent rayonne de ses yeux
est plus qu'un simple sourire et un
épanouissement de khalis tristesse sans
nom qui fleurissent sous un rayon du
noir soleil du destin plus que jamais
elisabeth a le désir de se retirer le
monde
elle sillonne l'europe à bord d'un wagon
salon de 9 mètres quel faire attacher
aux express internationaux en mer elle
vogue abordé miramar et lors des
tempêtes les plus effroyables
elle se fait attaché au mât pour ne rien
perdre du spectacle je fais comme
faisait ulysse parce que les vagues
bâtir la vie à bord est plus qu'un
simple voyage
c'est une vie plus vrai une vie idéale
chimiquement pur cristallisé sans désir
et sans conscience du temps au maire à
toi je ferai don de toutes mes pensées
et je plongerai en toi mon être égarée
tu es mon premier espoir au matin et
vers toi au crépuscule va mon dernier
regard sur l'île enchanteresse de corfou
l'impératif fait construire en 1892
un palais de marbre l'acquis les hommes
j'ai déjà vu beaucoup de belles choses
mais rien au monde dépasse cette île mon
coeur n'arrive pas à se rassasier de
tant de beauté
constantin cristaux manos qui lui
enseigne le grec découvre le palais elle
me fit voir tout le château pièce par
pièce
c'était comme un conte de fées dans ces
pièces là mis toute son âme elles sont
la chose la plus exquise mans politique
que l'on puisse imaginer et que l'on
rêverait de trouver en cet endroit
j'ai tout arranger moi même dit elle et
moi même choisi chaque but
il y avait là des sièges bien façonné
comme celui qu adraste offrit à hélène
incrusté d'argent et d'ivoire
à
de chaque coin de ses pièces le chantant
tristesse rayonne partout des teintes
finira des parfums qui expire d orthez
rni d'autrefois des lumières qui
pâlissent
en ce lieu chaque matin ressemble au
premier matin du monde
c'est l'oeuvre ou après une brève nuit
l'impératrice quitte ses appartements
pour goûter les premières lueurs de
lampes par le bruit mélodieux des
fontaines et le parfum du jasmin devant
chaque colonne du péristyle se dressent
des muses de marbre grandeur nature au
milieu d'elle elisabeth apparaît à
constanta christophe manas comme une
déesse jeu reconnaissait que les sources
à son approche chanter d'autres sorte
que les contours des rochers
s'infléchissent et en purines de beauté
que les pierres elle-même exhaler un
odorant souffle que les feuilles des
arbres sans apparition près ça y est
comme lorsqu elles s'attendent le soleil
est désolé s'affaisser cantal celoni
à l'extrémité du jardin tout au bout une
cache blanche resplendit c'est achille
mourant auquel j'ai consacré mon palais
parce qu'il personnifie pour moi l'amour
grecque et la beauté de la terre et des
hommes
je l'aimais aussi parce qu'il était si
rapide à la course il était fort et
altier et il a méprisé tous les rois et
toutes les traditions et compter les
foules humaines pour rien bonne
seulement à être fauché par la mort
comme des épi il n'a tenu pour sacrer
que sa propre volonté et n'a vécu que
pour ses rêves et sa tristesse lui était
plus précieuse que la vie entière un
matin elle trouve constantin sur la
terrasse avant l'aube elle dit je suis
toujours ici avant le lever du soleil
pour voir comment la nature s'éveille
veuillez ne plus venir à cette heure
c'est le seul moment je suis tout à fait
seul dans ce jardin de rêve
elisabeth relie les poèmes de henry il
me semble que parfois une nostalgie
secrète troubles ton regard
or je connais bien ton mal existence
manqué amour manquer tu consens avec
tristesse
non je ne veux pas te rendre ta jeunesse
ton mal n'a pas de remède amour manqué
existence manquer l'opératrice se dérobe
alors à tous les regards et chaque
apparition suscite l'admiration
soudain refus devant moi sans que je lui
son temps et venir sur lt droite sa tête
se détacher sur le fond d'une ombrelle
blanche irradiant de soleil du nez c'est
une sorte de nam vaporeux autour de son
front ses yeux d'or clair me regarder
fiction comme elle ressemblait peu à
tous les portrait que je connaissais je
me trouvais devant une apparition des
plus idéales et des plus tragiques de
l'humanité elisabeth est poursuivi par
l'idée de la mort si j'étais arriver
n'importe où et que je suis ce que je ne
pourrais m'en éloigner jamais plus le
séjour dans un paradis même deviendrait
l'enfer
la pensée d'abandonner bientôt un
endroit les murs qui me fait aimer
ainsi jean terre chaque fois un rêve
proto évanoui pour soupiré après un
autre qui n'est pas encore né
malgré son désir de fuir la vie factice
des cours nous faut encore elisabeth
rempli son rôle d'impératrice rennes
pour la célébration du millénaire de la
hongrie le 30 avril 1896
toute de noir vêtue elle est toujours
belle mais semble étonnamment intel au
milieu de ce peuple qu'elle aime tant le
cardinal primat de hongrie lui rend un
hommage appuyé à ces thèmes le sam un
temps de maternelle la reine elizabeth a
tissé julien doré qui relie à présent la
nation à son académie mais la souveraine
muette efforts pâle ne peut chasser de
sa mémoire le souvenir d'un rodolphe qui
a nommé s'en était à ses côtés lors des
cérémonies et des inaugurations
elisabeth revient parfois viennent
assumer ses fonctions
avec le temps les liens du couple se
sont distendus françois-joseph pour se
consoler des absences de l'impératrice a
trouvé en la jeune comédienne
catharines h rate une amie cependant ni
par la douleur commune de la perte de
rodolphe l'empereur et l'impératrice ce
ménage des instants d'intimité comme les
petits déjeuners qu'ils prennent souvent
en tête à tête en novembre 1896 le tsar
de russie nicolas ii et vos sur la cour
de vienne
elisabeth accepte de participer aux
cérémonies officielles
comme toujours elle apparaît triste est
absente mais pendant le dîner il s'anime
lorsqu'elle s'entretient avec le tsar de
la hongrie qui lui tient à coeur le cap
martin près de menton est un lieu de
villégiature prisé par elisabeth c'est
une impératrice fatigués de vivre que
l'on aperçoit marchant le long de la mer
le temps en temps françois-joseph vialli
retrouver
à 59 ans il a gardé sa mince silhouette
sculptée des années durant par les
régimes la marche à outrance et
l'anorexie mentale au cap martin
elisabeth croise parfois génie
l'impératrice des chriqui vasily vers
les deux femmes en grande taille ont
vécu la même tragédie
la perte de leur fils unique le 4 mai
1897 le destin frappe encore elisabeth
sa plus jeune soeur sophie charlotte
duchesse d'alençon disparue tragiquement
dans l'incendié du bazar de la charité
la malédiction qui pèse sur ma famille
grandit et devient toujours plus
menaçante durant l'été 1898 le couple
impérial et réunit abad eshop
dans la kaiser villa elisabeth retrouve
l'intimité de son bureau et confiait au
journal sa lassitude de vivre j'aspire
la mort je ne la crains pas car je ne
puis imaginer une puissance non contente
des souffrances de cette vie assez cruel
point chez l'homme du corps afin de
continuer à le torturer
elle se réfugie souvent dans le pavillon
qu'elle s'est fait construire au fond du
parc
elle aime également parcourir les allées
avec son compagnon que le destin lui a
assigné et qu'elle n'a pu mais que de
loin elle sent qu'elle n'a pas donné à
son mari et l'amour qu'ils attendaient
j'ai rêvé cette nuit que tu t'es mort
est mon coeur était douloureusement et
demi est-ce que je n'aurais pas détruit
naguère ta joie de vivre
le 16 juillet l'impératrice malades par
vers la suisse à la rencontre de son
destin
françois joseph lui chris dernière ligne
tu me manques infiniment et pensées sont
près de doigts et je souffre à l'idée de
cette longue absence
à genève la piraterie et sa suite se
sont installés à l'hôtel beau rivage
au total onze personnes escorte la
source
on
genève c'est mon lieu de séjour favoris
parce que je puis marché amaguiz parmi
les gens que son pôle it
cela me donne l'illusion d'être vraiment
tel que chacun devrait être accueillie
et des jeunes et la patronne du lit dans
read qui lui fait les honneurs de sa
maison elle apprécié le repas raffiné
dont elle expédié ensuite le menu à
l'empereur
au matin du 10 septembre elisabeth sort
faire quelques achats pour sa fille
marie valérie il est 13 heures
lorsqu'elle rentre à l'hôtel ou avec un
étrange sentiment contemple longuement
le quai du mont-blanc
émerge de ces songes que lorsque la
comtesse star et frappe à la porte
la presse de partir afin de ne pas
manquer le bateau elisabeth terminent
eux voient un verre de lait enfile son
manteau et quitte l'hôtel lentement
comme si chaque nuit était soudainement
devenu plus précieuse et qu'elle voulait
retarder l'échéance
sur le quai parce que désert à cette
heure il isabelle admire les marronniers
dit à la comtesse l'empereur m'a écrit
que cet automne quelques marronniers
coustans fleurs aliens les deux femmes
suaad vers le bateau lorsqu elles
aperçoivent anachronique se dirige vers
elle tint pas rapide
s'arrêtant devant l'impératrice l'homme
lui enfonce avec violence une ligne dans
la poitrine
elisabeth s'affaisse mais croyant
qu'elle a été simplement bousculer elle
ne réalise pas qu'un coup mortel vient
de lui apporter plein de dignité
elle se relève et se dirige vers le
bateau c'est sur le pont qu'elle perd
connaissance et en dégrafant son corsage
la comtesse découvre la blessure du
milieu des cris elizabeth se meurt
lentement on la transporte une civière
vers l'hôtel on espère encore la sauver
elle avait pressenti
je m'en irai comme la fumée sans voir
mon âme s'enfuira par une toute petite
ouverture du quart de la panique
générale l'assassin est arrêté il
s'appelle luigi loukine et c'est un
anarchiste italien de 25 ans qui s'était
juré de tuer une personnalités haut
placées à l'hôtel beau rivage
elisabeth s'éteint comme elle a vécu -
deviennent plus ambitieux ce jour là
chambre une lampe l'horreur écrit à sa
femme
j'ai perdu mon moral qui perce dans ta
lettre et de la satisfaction pour ton
appartement
tu dois avoir de la terrasse une vue
merveilleuse soudain son aide de camp
fait irruption avec un télégramme sa
majesté l'impératrice grièvement blessé
puis une seconde dépêche suit sa majesté
l'impératrice décidé à l'instant
accablée par cette nouvelle tragédie
l'empereur ses cris rien ne me sera donc
épargné sur cette terre il confiera plus
tard
personne ne saura jamais comme je l'aimé
oh
us